P: How's it going bros! This is Markiplier here
P: Together with...
J: Jack
M: And PewwDiepie
P: Just a joke! It was us all along!
J: Lmao just a prank!
P: Why do I feel so, like you guys are gonna fuck me or something.
J: [lowered voice] Get ready bitch
M: I didn't feel that at all
P: I felt it, sitting like this in the middle
J: Pick which face you want
P: Who's more likely to?
P: Is what we are doing today.
M & J: Ohhhhhhhh
P: With consequences.
M: Oh jeez
J: Okay...
P: So we are gonna- I'm going to make a statement and you guys lift whoever you think is more likely to.
J: I getcha
P: And the one with most will do a consequence by the end *shifts uncomfortably*
P: This is a great idea!
J (in baby voice): Dis is da best!
M: This is like the chillest video I've ever recorded
P: Are you comfortable?
M: Oh god yeah
P: Okay that's all that matters.
J: Sleepy time!
P: Ok, they're a bit weird, so just go with it, alright?
J: Okay
P: Who is more likely to suck a dick for 1 million?
M: *confused* Dollars? Or subs?
P: Yes
*deep breaths* M: Ya know, I gotta go with-
*much laughter*
M: I volunteer on that one
*more laughter from all*
M: For a million dollars or subs um umm yeah I'm all for it
J: Dude for a million hotdogs I'd do it
P: Who is... looks the best naked?
M: me
M: Aha!
P: NOOO
*much laughter*
P: I agree, Markiplier.
M: *odd voice* Yeh, thank you!
M: Wait does that mean I lose, because I got the most votes?
P & J: Yeaah
J: *giggles* That's why I knew you'd pick yourself
M: awkh c'mon
P: A'right Mark has one point.
M:  Yaaaaay...
M: His head is falling off my stick.
P: Trust me, you do NOT wanna lose, Mark.
P: Who watches the most porn?
M: If we're talking, like, me a few years ago—
*PewDiePie chuckles*
M: Probably? But—
P: Hey!
P: Hey, I like these faces!
J: I thought everyone was gonna choose themselves and—
M:I—I intentionally kept back.
P: Who is more likely to be a drama queen?
J: Oh Fuckin easy
M: Yeah.
P: WHAAAAT!?!?!
P: Fuck you! Fuck you!
J: He picks himself and then he goes *Impersonates PewDiePie* WHAT
M: Jesus!
*laughter*
P: Okay, fine!
P: Who is most likely to die first?
M: Probably me
M: I've been in the hospital so much
P: Oh okay
J: Mark's closest out of all of us
M: Actually, I can't stop going into the hospital
P: Who is most likely to murder their-their partner?
*sinister music*
M: Partner?
P: Yes
Mark: I don't want to vote for anybody...
J: M-Mark's an angry aggressive man
M: NO I'M NOT! I'm a sweetheart
M: Screw you ya Irish bastard
P: Ya know what-
P: Fuck y- Fuck it...
M: God DAMMIT
*laughter*
J: I'd kill you guys
P: Who's more likely...
P: ...to take a selfie naked?
M: OHH JESUS
J: Just instantaneous
*laughing* P: I see a lot of Markipliers
J: Is it the same with the death one?
M: I- I...
M: I LOOK THE BEST NAKED
M: ITS UNDERSTANDABLE GUYS....
J: T-The same with the death one... P: YOU DON'T KNOW THAT!
J: The same with death... you've gotten the closest out of all three of us
M: yeah pretty much. My accidental- My accidental bulge pics.. OOPS
J: Your bathrobe
M: My bathrobe...
J: It's just a matter of time
M: I was wearing very tight leather pants and I was like
P: No I saw them
P: You showed them to me
Mark: Oh yeah
J: He ACCIDENTALLY showed his bulge...
M: I didn't look at it!
I did not notice!
[reads]
P: WHAT?!?
What are you trying to tell me??
J: Even your own family thought you were gay for a while.
P: EY! NO!
J: Ye
P: Okay, fine that's true but WHATEVER!
M: Well I mean I've kissed a guy before
P: I have too and it was horrible! That's why I will never do it again
J: I haven't  on purpose, accidentally yeah.
M and P: Wait how accidentally??
PewDiePie in the background: Wait did you kiss?
J: Like turning around and someone was there and lips touched
P: That does not happen
M: Mine was a game of truth or dare
Felix: That does not happen!
J: It.. happened to me
I don't even think that counts as a kiss
P: HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN? Just turn around??
M: Leaning forward, lips first *kissing noises* OOPS!
J: It was in like primary school too and I was so embarrased and everyone made fun of me
Okay tell us your story then
P: aahh.. well it was me and two close friends
And two girls
in a hot tub and the girls were like:
"You guys should kiss and then we kiss "
And I was like 'no'.
J: Hell yeah girl!
P: Yeah well my friend was like UEEUEGH
P: without even hesitating!
and I'll never forget his face it was horrible!
J: How could you not relay back from him?
P: I did! I was stu- I was sitting down!
M: I remember I was at Bob's place
And we were all playing Truth or dare- I didn't kiss Bob-
J: Ahh man. M:uhhh... I kissed his friend Bristen
And so we were playing truth or dare
Jack: No one's named Bristen!
M: That was his name I didn't make that up
Yeah but anyways it was just like it was like truth or dare. This girl would show us her boobs
if we kiss and it was like
Alrightttt ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
J: You guys are easily coerced into like female nudity, female on female action..
P: Who is more likely to cry during a movie?
J: That's all mee
P and M: Really? *surprised*
J: Yeah
M: Oh I get so teary
J: Yeah same
P: OH Edgar I got Markiplier!
MArkk! It's MARrkk
J: Mark cries all the time!
P: Who's more likely to suck a dick to save their YouTube channel?
Yeah.. I'd do that.. Yeah...
J: Don't we all suck YouTube's dick already?
M: Who's more likely to have crash and burn after their career dies?
M: Who'd be more likely to cut off a limb for success?
M: wait is that me?
J: You did yourself
Mark: Oh I thought that was Felix!
J: No
Mark: Dangit...
J: You came up with the question so it's in the head there somewhere
J: Who's most likely to run into a burning building to save someone?
P: I'm no gonna do that
M: You wouldn't do that?
P: No, fuck that
M: really?
P: Who's more likely to have a sex change?
P: Fuck
P: Dammittt
Why do I even ask?
J: OH! Mark's losing!
M: WHAT? Why am I losing?
That's bullshit!
P: One point.... Well that was the game
J: Yayyyy
P: Bring in the punishment!
Ohhoohh Mark...
M: What's the punishment?
P: You're not gonna like this
M: OH WE JUST BOUGHT THAT
OhhhHHOH noooo...
J: Edgar, you don't want part of this
P: Edgar trust me you don't want this
M: I'm gonna be so embarrassed if milk actually comes out
P: WOAH it started right away
You're gonna like this!
M: I don't think I'm gonna like this...
P: Romania is telling me that Jack got equal amount of points
So Jack has to do it too
J: Uh no!
Micheal give me the sheet, give me the sheet
This is the scoring system! I had the least!!
P: You can put it where ever you want
M: On my nips apparently...
P: Sorry
J: They don't even go that far...
M: My nips are too spread >.<
P: Okay so I'm going to-
J: is that good?
M: no
J: Okay, so in case you don't know, these are vibrating nipple  pumps
M: I HAVE VERY SENSITIVE NIPS AAAHH GODDD!!
P: I'm gonna try and pump it a little bit
J: Dude look at that, stop pumping!
Holy shett!!
M: OHMYGODDD!
OH MY GODD!!
J: Those are fully erect nips right there
*grunting and yelling*
J: Dude that's insane, I don't know if this was worth it
P: I don't know how to turn it off
M: ohmygodstopthe-
J: Oh God, ooh. those vibrate a lot!
P: yea, very good.
You get one, I get one
Jack: Okay
Mark: I have SUPER sensitive nips!
M: Nice
J: God
P: Hell yeah bro!
J: HELL YEAH.
P: Pump it up yeah bro
J: Oh My God!
M: I KNOW I KNOW I KNOW XD
F: The pump!
M: It's NOT pleasant!
J: Turn on the vibration
M: Yeah turn on the vibrate
P: ooh I like vibration
Jack: oooh
P: OOOOHHOHOHHHHHOHH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
J: Nice, I'm into it...
P: Look at that!!!
Did you see that shit!?!?
M: haha yup
J: I like it
It's not that bad.
M: Mine still tingle
P: Well... I uh
J: The full visceral experience
P: Alright, now it's time for
J: Oh God
P: Jack would you do the honors?
M: I don't think it's gonna seal to your gooch, but
J: Doesn't matter, it'll vibrate.
M: Alright
J: Okay you hold that one there
P: ooh, well thank you guys for coming on
J: There's too much fabric
P: And uhh, like this video if you enjoyed
We're gonna *gets cut off by Jack-a-boy*
J: I'm SURE people enjoyed this
Is it working?
P: No
If you gonna do it, you gotta do it right OHOOOH!!!
P: Well thank you guys so much for watching, thanks to
thanks to Felix
and oh Felix!
great
Check out Markiplier and Jack I'll leave a link in the description
Thanks for leaving a like and as always
bros, we do the brofist
Ye,
J: since when do you do the brofist anymore?
P: as always!
I do this, so fucking weird
P: Get a little closer Mark
M: Sorry
J: This is how the thumbnails are maaade
P: That's cool
that looks cool
okay, cool
FUKCKEN SUBSCROOBE YE BETCH
I'm editing this on Christmas!!!